-♪♪ "Tonight Show:
Cooler Heads" ♪♪
♪♪ "Tonight Show:
♪♪ "Tonight Show" ♪♪
-All right, Higgins,
tell us how the game works.
-Well, it's very simple.
You'll each be taking turns
answering multiple choice
football trivia questions.
Once your answer's locked in,
two coolers will be carried out
and dumped over your heads.
[ Laughter ]
If you answer correctly,
your cooler will be empty
and your opponent will be doused
with a mystery substance.
[ Laughter ]
-Why are you looking at me for?
-He answers correctly,
you get dumped on.
Any questions?
-Yeah, I was just wondering --
-Great.
First question is for Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, here we go.
-Ready?
-This is football trivia.
-Football trivia.
In 1892 --
-Oh, come on.
[ Light laughter ]
Give me a real one.
-Who became the first --
-For real?
-Yes, for real.
-1892?
-1892.
-I don't know anything
that happened in 1892.
Columbus?
-That's his year, man.
He's totally 1892.
Who became the first
professional football player
when he was paid $500
to play in a game?
Was it, A, Harry Tickler.
-What?
-B, Harry Testes.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on. Come on.
-Or, C, "Pudge" Heffelfinger.
A, B, or C.
-It's not Harry Testes,
obviously.
[ Light laughter ]
-Could be. Could be.
You never know.
Why would something that crazy
be in there?
-It was a popular name
back in the day.
[ Light laughter ]
-1892.
-Harry Tickler. A.
Final answer.
-You're going to say
Harry Tickler?
You're locked in?
-Who is Harry Tickler?
-Okay, let's get those coolers
out here.
It's locked in.
[ Drumroll ]
Let's see if he was right.
Three, two, one, dump!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! You were wrong.
You were wrong.
-Should have gone with Testes.
-Yeah, you should have went
with Testes.
The answer was C,
"Pudge" Heffelfinger.
-Was there ice in there?
-It was icy cold eggnog.
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Can we see that in slow motion?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh. Freezing.
-That was a lot.
[ Whistle blows ]
-Score is 7-0.
Next question is for James.
Hey, James.
-Hi.
[ Laughter ]
-What the hell just happened?
-I can feel how cold
that is from here.
-The hell just happened?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, gosh.
-It's freezing.
-You gotta sit in it.
-Ice cold. This is a nightmare.
-He's sitting in it.
-Ice cold.
Okay. James.
-What is this here for?
[ Laughter ]
-That's to wash off your hands.
-Useless!
-What the hell am I going to do
with this stupid thing?
It's already to be soaking wet
with eggnog.
All right, let's go.
Next question.
-Ready?
-This is ridiculous.
-You want us to hurry up because
you're kind of cold.
-Yeah, I hate this game.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, in 1892.
-This is a different one.
What inspired Kansas City Chiefs
owner Lamar Hunt --
[ Cheers and applause ]
God bless you --
to coin the term "Super Bowl"
in 1966?
Was it, A,
bowl-shaped stadiums?
B, his son's Super Ball toy?
Or, C, his favorite
Superman comic?
What was it?
That's a tough one.
-That's a good one.
-That's a brain buster.
That's a noodle burner.
[ Laughter ]
What are you going to say,
James?
1966.
-It's seeping into my underwear.
-I mean, I know...
-Lamar Hunt.
-...DC is, you know,
really popular thing right now,
"Justice League" and all that.
But I'm going to say
the Super Bowl --
like his son's toy,
the Super Ball toy.
-You're going to say B,
the Super Ball toy?
-B, B, B.
-Answer's locked in.
Answer's locked in.
The Super Ball toy.
Get the coolers out here.
-Get ready, dude.
It ain't no Super Ball toy.
-Let see if it's right!
Three, two, one, dump!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! You are correct.
You are correct, James!
That was tinsel.
You look like Cher.
Can we see that in slow motion?
-Why?
[ Laughter ]
Super Ball toy?
-Yeah.
-How the heck
would you know that?
-Lamar Hunt.
-Okay.
This is ridiculous.
-Everyone loves Lamar Hunt.
-Super Ball toy. Okay.
Give me a real question.
-All right. Ready?
It's a barn burner.
-Give me something I know.
-14-0.
[ Light laughter ]
James is in the lead.
This next question is for you.
-I know who's in the lead.
-Next question.
-Really? Is he winning?
-Yes, he's winning.
It's 14 -- you have 14.
-I didn't know who was winning.
-You have zero.
-I smell like eggnog.
-14-0.
[ Whistle blows ]
Ready?
[ Laughter ]
Which of these artists --
-If Harry Testes is an answer --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Which of these artists
have never --
that is, never performed at
a Super Bowl Halftime Show?
Is it, A,
New Kids on the Block?
B, Taylor Swift?
Or, C, The Rolling Stones?
Now what are you going to say?
New Kids --
-Did New Kids do it?
New Kids or Taylor Swift.
I saw The Rolling Stones.
-Right.
-[ Groans ]
Oh, I don't think Swifty did it.
I say B, Taylor Swift
has never performed.
-Answer's locked in.
-Yes.
-It's locked in.
Let's get the coolers out here.
[ Drumroll ]
-I hate you guys!
-Let's see if Taylor Swift
is the correct answer.
Three, two, one, dump!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, oh, my gosh.
James got battered with popcorn.
-What?
-Multi-flavor popcorn.
Can we see that in slow motion?
-No, why?
That's all you got?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Caramel corn, cheese corn,
and butter corn.
-How does he get popcorn?
-That's nuts.
[ Light laughter ]
-This is the most rigged thing
I've ever done
in my entire life.
-Score is James 14, Jimmy 7.
-All right.
-I cannot believe.
[ Whistle blows twice ]
-You know what that
double whistle means.
-No.
-It's time for
the final question.
-All right.
-There's a twist.
-Yeah, what's that?
-This is a question worth
a touchdown,
plus a two-point conversion,
so that's eight points.
So Jimmy, technically --
technically,
you could still win.
-Let's do it.
-And this is your question,
James.
-I feel good.
I feel like a winner.
-If you get this right, you win.
-Okay.
-If you get it wrong...
-All right, we got it.
-...glitter man's the winner.
-Yeah, glitter man.
Glitter man.
Coming this summer.
[ Laughter ]
-Stuck on there with egg nog.
-All right, James.
-Yes.
-What is the only team
in history
to win three NFL championships
in a row?
-I have no idea.
-Was it, A,
the Green Bay Packers?
B, the Dallas Cowboys?
Or, C, the Pittsburgh Steelers?
-Oh.
-Oh, this is for James.
-Yeah, for James?
-Oh, great.
-This is it.
Green Bay Packers.
-You're going to say
the Green Bay Packers?
Answer's locked in.
Let's get the coolers out here.
This is for the whole thing.
-Better not be popcorn
this time.
-Let's see who the winner is.
Three, two, one, dump!
[ Ding! ]
[ Audience "ohs" ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That means --
that was Buffalo wing sauce.
Which means James is the winner!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Whistle blows ]
-Fist bump!
-You can't even shake my --
This is the dumbest game
I've ever played on this show.
The champion,
James Franco, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Niall Horan, everybody.
What is going on, dude?
-[ Indistinct rapping ]
♪♪♪♪